Lyne wrote to me saying Lin Lin says
David should parents be able to choose
the sex of their children beyond
situations where the baby has been
determined to be intersexed so I think
sometimes it's more interesting to start
with why should something not be allowed
and then why should it be allowed and
it's a sort of libertarian perspective
which is unless you have a really
specific reason not to allow something
to ban something then it should be
allowed period and unfortunately the
points against gender selection often
devolve into slippery slope arguments
like for example if you were able to
choose the sex of your child and it was
allowed next thing you know parents
would be able to because science will
advanced select anything they want about
their children and you were going to see
less diversity in terms of the way
people look and you're going to see a
very homogenous and boring society and
there are going to be problems in terms
of people sort of having the same
physical identity in some ways or
everybody's going to be sort of have DNA
altered to be smarter in the way that
we've talked about being potentially
possible in the future
there are also arguments which say
gender sex selection in this way is a
frivolous use of medical resources there
is some finite amount of medical
resources that exist and allowing
parents to pick the sex of their child
is just sort of a misuse because it's
not necessary it's not relevant it's not
something that should happen and then
this sort of leads into one of the more
common arguments I hear which is we just
shouldn't interfere with the lottery of
child birth I don't know I don't know
how I feel about that because when you
look at the arguments in favor of sex
selection for children you say we'll
listen number one there are parents who
want a specific they want a boy or a
girl and you may have situations where
you will prevent either abortion or
infanticide because parents got the baby
that was not the
sex that they wanted so by allowing them
to pick you're going to reduce the
number of parents that either choose
abortion or infanticide at some point
during the fetus or baby's life okay
that that's interesting there's
something to that another argument and
this is more of a practical argument is
if you don't allow it but it becomes
medically possible people are going to
find a way to do it and it will be
unregulated it will be the equivalent of
the back-alley abortion you are way
better off if you concede you can't
prevent it definitively in regulating it
and saying okay here are the guidelines
we've established for safe and ethical
sex selection here is how where and when
it has to be done or whatever I don't
know okay so that's sort of a practical
argument and then another argument is
basically just a broader freedom
argument which is if nobody is getting
hurt parents should have freedom of
choice it if you if you can't make a
very specific and strong argument as to
why you would ban something then it
should be allowed because it is part of
the freedom of choice that parents
should have where do I come down on this
I take a more practical approach I do
not believe that you are going to be
indefinitely able to prevent this from
being done and I think we are way way
better off regulating it and allowing it
and I want to go one step further if
you're worried about overpopulation
okay and this is not something I've
heard discussed often I know many
couples who say okay we had a daughter
we're going to have another child
because we also really want to have a
boy and then they have a second daughter
and then they say you know what we're
going to have another child because we
really want to have a boy if they had
been able to select a boy for that
second child it would be very unlikely
that they would have continued having
children and if you have a concern about
consumption of resources on earth if you
have a concern about overpopulation then
this is a way to sort of allow a control
for that by allowing people to just have
the children that they want and that's
that now you can make a counter argument
which is well what if parents really
want to have a choice
that is over 6 feet tall not a great
example because by the time you know but
that the child will be 6 feet tall or
not you may have gone beyond the age at
which you can birth a child if you're a
woman but you sort of get the idea how
far can you go with this idea of hey you
should just be able to pick everything
and my prediction is because of the way
medical science is going you're going to
be able to go pretty far in choosing
traits for children
I say allow it regulate it and do it
safely